oh
uh
it's
[Music]
i think
oh
oh
yes
don't you worry
so
thank you very much mr chairman uh thank
you for being back
your honor and thank you to your family
as well
uh i want to just begin by saying
uh perhaps not surprisingly to you that
i was
uh really disappointed by your responses
to a number of my colleagues most
recently to
senator coons on the issue of whether
you would
participate in the decision involving
the upcoming election
if you are confirmed
i continue to believe that if you were
to participate
in a decision involving that election it
would do
enduring explosive damage to the court
i think you know it would be wrong
not because of anything you've done in
fact i'm not
raising the issue of whether you've done
any sort of deal or commitment
because of what donald trump has done
and
my republican colleagues because
they have
indelibly put at issue your integrity
through their statements the president
has said that he's putting you on the
court
as a ninth justice so you can decide
the election it's been very clear
and transparent and the american people
are not dumb
they're watching and they're listening
and if you were to sit
on this case if it goes to this
supreme court the american people would
lose
faith and trust in the court itself it
would be a
dagger at the heart of the court and our
democracy
if this election is decided by the court
rather than the american voters so i
wanted to begin
by making that point and then go to
uh again the real people
who are really in this room with us and
who will be affected
by you as a justice yesterday i
introduced you to
conor kern you may recall he's 10 years
old
i was with him on his 10th birthday
september 27th he's a remarkable
champion he was diagnosed as you may
remember with
duchenne muscular dystrophy at age four
his parents
were told to take him home and give him
a good life
because he would soon lose his ability
to walk
told his muscles would get so weak that
he'd eventually
lose his ability to smile
and still smiling
what lies behind that smile is
untold pain physical pain the anguish of
going through the needles and the
prodding and the treatments
but for his family it's also the anguish
of
wondering whether they'll be able to pay
for treatment that has kept him
alive and whether he will be with them
for
all of life's milestones
they sent me a letter
that they asked me to
share with you saying to you
judge barrett please protect conor
and they wrote also for millions of
other americans 135
million americans many of them children
just like conor but also
christine miller from bloomfield
connecticut she was diagnosed with a
thyroid condition her
condition was only discovered because of
the aca
which gave her affordable coverage for
the first time in a long time
using connecticut's exchange healthcare
exchange
and they wrote for people like julia
lanzano in cheshire connecticut
she suffered from headaches for years
and she put off going to a doctor
because she lacked insurance so
typical and common for people put it off
when julia finally saw a doctor without
still without insurance
she learned she had a brain tumor and
she was eligible for coverage
under connecticut's medicaid expansion
program
which was created by the affordable care
act
in her words it was a godsend
i raised these stories in part because
as you know i'm sure
protection for people who suffer from
pre-existing conditions is in fact
on the line in
this case that will come to the supreme
court
only a week after the election
i want to be crystal clear because you
stated to
senator feinstein that
and i'm going to quote
so far as i know the case next week
doesn't present that issue
it's not a challenge to pre-existing
conditions coverage
or to the extreme lifetime maximum
relief from a cap
and technically you're right but
it's a big but if the
trial court is upheld and there's no
severability
the entire act goes down
that is what the trump administration is
asking the court to do that's what the
plaintiffs want done
correct um i gathered that
senator coons had shown the brief with
the litigating position of the
department of justice
i want to move on uh to
[Music]
another
health care case
and this one
[Music]
involves some of the letters
that senator hawley was mentioning
and i feel i need to raise them because
senator hawley asked about them so did
senator leahy
and i want to just clarify
what they mean and i want to make
absolutely clear uh i
detest and oppose any religious tests
i am not asking you any questions about
your religious beliefs
okay i'm going to be asking some
questions about your legal
positions so in case i'm unclear on any
of my questions i want
you to tell me thank you senator um you
signed on to this
2006 open letter
sponsored by an organization then known
as the st joseph's county
right to life which was published in the
south bend
tribune is that the letter that senator
hawley was
mentioning i believe he the statement
that's on the left
i think senator hawley had read the
language
i can't remember it verbatim but it was
something like
you know we support the right to life
from fertilization to natural death
yes the
letter and add referred to roe v wade's
legacy as quote unquote barbaric
correct i don't think that that's part
of the statement
i think that's part of the ad that
appeared on the page next to it
they appeared side by side correct i
believe that it ran that way in the
newspaper i'm not sure that i ever saw
it in the newspaper
but yes that that is my understanding
that's how it appeared so they were side
by side that's based yes based on since
and uh this joseph's county
right to life sponsored the letter that
you sign
um i think the saint joseph county right
to life
organization was the one who presented
the statement that i signed at the back
of church
i want to give you an opportunity uh to
clarify
you didn't disclose that letter when you
were nominated to the 7th circuit
in 2017 did you um i did not senator
blumenthal and i'm actually very glad
that you brought that up because
i just want to clarify for the record um
number one that i didn't have any
recollection of that letter i signed an
almost
earth statement i signed it almost 15
years ago
quickly on my way out of church and
you know this questionnaire asks me for
30 years worth of material
and i've produced more than 1800 pages
and so i didn't recall it after it came
to my attention
i did go back and look at the
questionnaire and i actually don't think
that
particular statement is responsive to
question 12
which is i think the closest that it
would come i don't think it's responsive
but
in any event it is part of the public
you know record and i'm very happy to
discuss it but it wasn't
record now and it's a letter the
questionnaire
asks for letters have you
[Music]
disclosed it now have you provided it
officially
um so senator as i said i've
supplemented my questionnaire
with other material that came to light
that i do think was responsive
that one and i would be happy to answer
questions if you wanted questions for
the record with more specific detail
but i did not understand that to be
responsive
to question 12 i think it is
well in fact we know about it only
because the guardian
made it public i believe let me ask you
about
another letter 2013 letter you signed on
to
this letter regarding roe v wade
it was sponsored by the university
faculty for life at notre dame
you're a member of that organization
correct i do
and the letter described roe v wade as
uh behind me infamous
and it stated that the signatories
quote renew our call for the unborn to
be protected in law
correct um yes i believe the full
statement says i'm testing my eyesight
here
our full support for our university's
commitment to the right to life because
you know notre dame is a catholic
university and embraces the teachings of
the catholic church on abortion
and so as a faculty member and member of
the university faculty for life i signed
that statement
but you didn't disclose that letter
again senator i produced 1800 pages of
material and all six
prior nominees have had to supplement
because they've overlooked things 30
years worth of material is a lot to try
to find and remember
you disclosed it in fact just about
three days ago i believe right because
that's when it was brought to my
attention i had no recollection of it
and it surfaced in the press and so it
came to my attention
and then i supplemented and i did think
it was responsive because it was a
statement
of an organization of which i was part
and i belonged to the university faculty
for life at the time
if this process maybe had been a little
less
rushed you might have had more time to
go back and recall some of these
documents well senator as i said all
six prior nominees or the most recent
six have had to supplement too
so i don't think it really had anything
to do with time i think it has to do
with the volume of material
and when you and i spoke when you appear
before this committee in connection with
your
2017 nomination i didn't have the
benefit of any of these documents
although i asked you about
right of privacy and the validity of roe
v wade
senator i said on my sjq
when i was nominated to the 7th circuit
and i said again now i produced all the
material
that i could find and i conducted
searches to try to find things that i
forgot and i didn't find that i
understand that
someone had to manually go to notre dame
and look through back archives
i i didn't remember it and i couldn't
find it i assure you i was not trying to
hide it from you so
judge and i apologize for interrupting
you no press for time
uh sure respectfully i want to
share another healthcare story with you
uh
is about samantha one night
in january 2017 samantha went out with a
few friends and co-workers
she woke up the next morning in a
co-worker's home confused
scared covered in blood she'd been raped
after she was raped samantha was in her
words
a zombie she couldn't change clothes she
couldn't shower she couldn't drink
or think she wanted this event to be
erased from her memory
samantha's attacker also began stalking
her
and she was struggling with depression
and ptsd
in march samantha took a pregnancy test
and then another then another
they kept coming back with the same
result
pregnant after the horrible
violence she faced she simply couldn't
process that she was now
pregnant when samantha shared her story
with me she said
i knew if i couldn't end this pregnancy
it would end me
so she decided to get an abortion
now as you know judge
the landmark roe v wade decision gave
her
that option it gave women the right to
decide
for themselves whether and when to have
a child
roh didn't compel samantha to get an
abortion it didn't tell her what she had
to do but it gave her
that choice
the question that
i would like to ask you concerns
your legal position
does the constitution protect
samantha's right to have
an abortion rule versus wade
clearly held that the constitution
protected a woman's right to terminate a
pregnancy
casey upheld that central holding and
spelled out in greater detail the test
that the court
uses to consider the legality of
abortion regulations
now i'm asking you this question because
the
group that sponsored
the first letter saint joseph's county
right to life as it was then known
states quote abortion is never the right
answer
even in cases of sexual assault or where
the pregnant woman's life is in danger
and the purpose of the letters that you
signed
seemed to be a statement of legal
position but you're saying
that there is a constitutional
right to an abortion senator the
statement
that i signed from the saint joseph
county right to life
didn't say anything about rape or
ancestor any of those things it simply
validated the teaching of my church
on the sacredness of life from
conception to natural death
what i hear you saying is in the
constitution
there is that right i you mean when i
was talking about row and casey a moment
ago
well bro was correctly decided you're
agreeing that
what i said was that roe held
that the constitution protects a woman's
right to terminate a pregnancy that
casey reaffirmed that holding and indeed
many cases after casey have affirmed
that holding
again whole women's health for example
um
so i i think we might be talking past
each other because the statements that i
signed were statements of my personal
beliefs and not
not your personal belief your honor your
legal position
are you willing to say that roe was
correctly decided because
that's really the essence of the
question here
um well senator as i've said you know to
others of your colleagues in response to
questioning
that it's inconsistent with the duties
of a sitting judge
and therefore has been the practice of
every nominee that sat in the seat
before me to take positions
on cases that the court has decided in
the past
well i think samantha and a lot of rape
survivors would be
really deeply fearful about
that answer because it provides no
reassurance that
you believe that bro was correctly
decided let me
talk about tracy i want to
tell you about her because she again
came to me told me she was diagnosed
with
stage four endometriosis
and that it had caused an ongoing
inability to have a healthy pregnancy
but as she said she was one of the quote
lucky ones she had access to care
and was able to receive treatment to
assist in getting and staying
pregnant
and i have encountered maybe you have
many members of the military veterans
who have sought similar kinds of
treatment some of them because they've
suffered
wounds of war tracy was scared
when she saw the executive director of
the saint joseph
county right to life recently stated and
i quote
we would be supportive of criminalizing
the discarding of frozen embryos or
selective reduction through the ivf
process
so tracy wanted me to ask you in fact
she asked me to
pose this question is it your legal
position
that making ivf a crime
would be constitutional well senator
the statement that i signed as we
discussed you know
affirmed the belief of my church with
respect to matters of life
i'm i'm not asking about what you sign
i'm asking about your present legal
position
is making ivf a crime senator
sorry go ahead sorry i was trying to
answer your but you're quoting positions
from the saint joseph county right to
life i'm not a member of that
organization
and so i'm not responsible for
statements that they make the statement
that i signed
said what you and i have discussed and
it said nothing further than that
and as for you know what policy position
someone might take you know as i've said
to your colleagues
i just it's not up to me to be in the
business of expressing
views and i am happy to talk about views
that i
expressed when i was a private citizen
but now i'm a judge
and so i cannot publicly express views
just to be
absolutely clear i'm not asking about
the saint joseph's county right to life
or
their positions and i understand you
may or may not disagree or agree with
them
but your legal position ivf
treatment and i'm not going to ask again
just this last time criminalizing it
would it be constitutional i think
there's a clear
answer but senator i've repeatedly said
as has
every other nominee who sat in this seat
that we can't answer
questions in the abstract that would
have to be decided in the course of the
judicial process
with a case some legislature would
actually have to do that
and then litigants would have to come to
court there would have to be briefs and
arguments and consultation with
colleagues and opinion writing and
consideration of precedent so an
off-the-cuff reaction to that would just
circumvent
the judicial process well
again i'm disappointed i think tracy
would find that response
somewhat chilling because
she and thousands maybe millions of
women potential parents
would be horrified to think that ivf
treatment could be made criminal and i
understand you're not answering the
question
but i think um she would be
deeply fearful do you think that it
would be constitutional to make it a
crime for doctors
or health care providers to provide
that care or abortion care
well senator again that's a hypothetical
question
and so as i've said to give off the cuff
responses about abstract issues and and
i should clarify to say
it really doesn't matter if they're hard
questions or easy questions
it's just any questions that call for an
abstract legal opinion
are not ones that are appropriate for me
to give either as a sitting judge
or as a nominee um those questions in my
judicial role can be answered only
through the judicial process
just to be absolutely clear there are
millions of women like samantha and
tracy
and the veterans i mentioned who are
terrified to think that their doctors
and health care providers would be
potentially in jail at risk of
prosecution
doctors who are exercising currently
protected rights
that samantha says saved
her life and i believe our
health care providers are heroes
particularly during
the pandemic but i want to ask you one
one more question
about these documents in the 2013 letter
that you signed uh there is a following
statement
um we renew our call
for the unborn to be protected in law
in law and welcomed in life
what does it mean for quote the unborn
to be protected in law does that
statement mean there is no valid
constitutional
protection for an abortion and therefore
roe v wade
should be overturned um you know i think
that statement
is an affirmation of life you know it
points out that we express our love and
support for the mothers who bear them
again it was a statement validating the
position of the catholic university at
which i worked
and support for life and to you know
support
women in crisis pregnancies to support
babies so it's it's
really no more than the expression of a
pro-life view
i expect we'll be talking more about
this issue tomorrow i want to move now
to uh
another topic uh you and senator durbin
and others talked about
your descent in cantor v bar
and i think your approach here
in effect usurps the legislature's
appropriate role
in making policy judgments
in the case of cantor which by the way
you put
first on the list of
decisions that you thought were most
important that
you have written is that correct i don't
remember the order in which i listed
them
it was first i i accept that i
i just don't remember the order okay i
did list it i remember listing it
okay um but
that decision seems to usurp the
legislature's role in deciding
who should be permitted to have firearms
and who should not
because you decided the legislature was
wrong
to classify felons as not
deserving of firearms you decided as a
matter of policy
that when they were not dangerous
they should have that right that's a
policy or legislative judgment and i
think it has
huge ramifications for
real people across the country and i
want to tell you about
one of them from sandy hook connecticut
natalie
who is shown here with her brother
daniel
daniel was killed at sandy hook
elementary school
in newtown connecticut on december 14
2012. dan daniel was
seven
i was there that day saw the parents
after they'd learned that they had
lost 20 beautiful children
and six great educators died as well in
the firehouse that day there was
unspeakable grief
and eight years later natalie says that
grief remains
with her but
natalie like newtown is resilient and
strong and her grief and trauma
spurred hope and action she and
many young people across the country are
leading a movement
to deal with the epidemic and scourge of
gun violence in this country
what happened at sandy hook was not an
isolated instance
there have been 236 other mass shootings
in the last decade in the last 10 years
gun violence has taken more than 354
000 lives in rural communities and urban
communities
all around the country and i'm sure in
indiana
and south bend as well
your opinion in canter
goes farther than justice scalia in
heller in fact you
characterized it as kind of radical
it is in effect an outlier
and it is in fact
radical did i say it was radical in the
opinion
i think you said quote
it sounds kind of radical to say
felons can have firearms that's a direct
quote
oh i didn't remember that particular
language
you can i i'm not i'm not
oh i just don't recall it but i'm not
nitpicking about it we can look it up
that's fine senator i i don't think
you're making it up trust me no i
i'll check it and look it up but i know
that's not the thrust of your question
it sounds kind of radical because it is
radical in fact uh no courts
of appeals except maybe the seventh
circuit
has adopted this reasoning the third
circuit i think has a rule that's
the third circuit any others i don't
know that it's
i knew there was one circuit that did i
wasn't sure which one
but my position was consistent with a
third circuit on bonk decision that had
already been decided
and cutting through all of the legalese
and we've had quite a bit of it going
back and forth
what this approach does potentially
is mean that connecticut's gun safety
provisions that
the people of newtown kristen and
michael song
on behalf of their son ethan who
perished
because of a gun that was
unsafely stored they championed a
measure called
ethan's law
sense measures that might have prevented
the death of
shane oliver janet rice's son
who died on october 20
2012.
shane was killed when he was 20 years
old in hartford
he died fighting for his life in
hartford hospital
and measures like the
emergency risk protection order that
connecticut now has
19 states have these laws
they've saved lives
and extreme risk protection order laws
which help minimize risk might
well be struck down under the reasoning
of your decision your dissent
respectfully senator my descent would
not reach even those issues
my dissent was about the narrow question
about whether a felon who
had sold fraudulent foot inserts
could automatically be disqualified from
his second amendment rights simply on
that basis it said that
guns can be kept out of the hands of the
dangerous
and it didn't say anything about other
gun safety
or background check those are all issues
that are being litigated across the
country and we're not at issue in canter
but supplanting the legislators judgment
about when
dangerous people should
be protected from themselves if they are
potential suicides as vic bencomo a
veteran
in iraq
found when his friend was going to take
his life the emergency risk protection
order would have been available
deciding what is dangerous who is
dangerous
when weapons should be taken away from
them if the courts are going to supplant
the judgments of legislatures if
judges are going to legislate from the
bench that's
the import of your reasoning in that
descent
it may not have dealt precisely with any
of these particular laws
but the reasoning
throws into doubt it raises the risk
to many of them and folks who live in
connecticut
are terrified of that prospect at least
tragedy um so i expressed the deepest
sympathy
for those who experienced that loss
there and elsewhere but
cantor you know i hope you take some
comfort from
cantor being a much narrower decision
that doesn't
have any effect on those sorts of laws
thank you senator thank you
thank you judge senator tillis thank you
mr chairman
thank you judge barrett uh mr chairman
before i get started i'd like
uh unanimous consent to submit a letter
from my primary care physician
indicating that it fully complied with
cdc guidelines being cleared
like 2000 other north carolinians
yesterday and i'm glad that they're
healing
without objection i'd also like to put
four three letters uh
in support of judge barrett including
one from devin patel a former
uh student who speaks very highly of
your academic prowess but also your
compassion
for that objection i also like to cover
what uh
senator blumenthal just did i think we
should go back i believe you alluded to
a judge barrett but
question 12a of the committee
questionnaire asked for books articles
reports letters to the editor editorial
pieces
or other published material you have
written or edited
is it fair to say that if you signed a
petition you did not
write or edit any of the petition you
signed i did not write
or edit that it also needs to be
restated i think you alluded to it but
over the last six justices confirmed by
this committee
all of them provided supplemental
information and in some cases
after the actual hearing um
so i appreciate your being forthcoming
that you've submitted 1800
pages of documents mr chairman just
going back i also wanted to mention that
as a part of my journey through
my time in quarantine i have enrolled in
two studies so far i'll be giving blood
on
uh friday to enroll in another program
at unc chapelville and i'm scheduled to
donate convalescent plasma because this
is being aired
i hope that anyone who's recovered from
covid will do their part to try and
heal this country from the health
challenges that covet has presented us
with i
intend to do my part i also would like
to say
i like to consider the senate an
essential business
and i believe that the architect of the
capital and our attending physicians
here have taken great measures to make
sure that we can safely come to work
and i would encourage anybody who works
in the senate to come to work
um i want to also go back to something
that
senator feinstein said earlier and
you're not going to have to answer this
question
senator feinstein mentioned earlier that
we've had a surge
in applications for guns or purchases of
guns
i wonder if a part of that is where we
find our society right now
we're seeing great cities burned and
looted and my highway patrol
in north carolina 75 percent fewer
applications to go into the troopers
academy
and record high requests for
retirement we see that in new york we
see it across this country i think
people are afraid because many people
including people on this committee are
unwilling to condemn the acts of
violence and public safety out there and
condemn
violence against law enforcement which
is rampant
i lost a a sheriff's deputy just about a
month ago
who was shot protecting a family so
yes senator feinstein i suspect that gun
purchases are up but i suspect the root
cause behind a lot of them
have to do with people's personal safety
to your family uh i would encourage all
your family members and your students
who mercifully are your your
your children who are your students too
who are mercifully taking a break to uh
treat
social media like roadkill just don't
look at it because if you do
you're going to regret it i am going to
also ask unanimous consent to put forth
uh some articles or tweets from
prominent people that i think kind of
give you an idea of the guerrilla
tactics that are being used right now in
the committee
this has sounded a whole lot like a
lobbying session it's almost as if
you're being interviewed to become a us
senator so that you can decide
policy on the on the affordable care act
a number of other things that i'll get
to
but behind the curtains we're seeing
people say all kinds of things about you
uh one record one called you a white
colonizer
for actually adopting two haitian
children we have another one calling you
a handmaid
and a clown and a clown car and i'm not
gonna i'm not it will be submitted for
the record but the profanity used in
there
uh another one uh that uh that says that
yeah you're a good mom but that doesn't
qualify you as a judge what qualifies
you as a judge is being an extraordinary
professor an extraordinary student and
an extraordinary jurist
and i think that these people need to
recognize doing the bidding of this
committee by attacking you outside of
the committee is as bad as them being in
this chamber
now i also want to talk about the
discussion on roe v wade in the
affordable care act
the senator feinstein
in i think the same two or three minutes
said that she wanted to to protect roe v
wade
but overturn heller those seem to be
incongruent
but i'll just leave that out there
they're asking you to basically
legislate i don't want you to do that
but when we talk about roe v wade the
one thing that's conveniently missed
about this
discussion is something that i think
that most of the american people
are at odds with the position that every
member of the democratic conference
supports
my um my granddaughter went to her
two-month uh health checkup today she
weighed in at 10
10.1 pounds and you can't see this
picture but i'm telling you from this
granddaddy's eyes she's gorgeous
but she was born three weeks premature
and she only weighed a little over six
pounds she was discharged from the
hospital within 36 hours
my colleagues on the other side of the
aisle want to talk about the broad
strokes of roe v wade
they don't want to talk about their
radical policy that would allow the
right to take that child away
that i just held in my arm two or three
weeks ago and eight weeks ago when she
was uh
three weeks uh three weeks premature
um judge barrett
i believe uh i have complete confidence
in your integrity
i have complete confidence that you're
going to go and you're going to be a
great justice but i do want to ask a
little bit about
your experience when you were working
for
actually i want to start when you were
in
in school did you have when you came in
you were obviously a brilliant student
you did your homework we've heard
professors attest your
um your intelligence and your
performance in school
did you ever go into a classroom where
the professor was espousing one position
and you were espousing another one and
you ended up coming out with a different
perspective
sure yeah uh did you ever change your
professor's perspective
i'm not sure about that well it's kind
of unfair balance
okay now fast forward to when you were a
clerk for justice scalia
i just saw an interview last week when i
was in quarantine of justice breyer
talking about these
mounds of uh of uh documents that his
clerks would provide him he'd quickly go
through him he said
it's actually a fairly quick process to
winnow out the ones where there's no
dispute among there's no split circuits
so
we move through it pretty quickly i
understand that
justice scalia at least in some sessions
would have a mix of clerks they would be
across the ideological spectrum was that
the case when you were clerking for him
i would say that not all four of us he
had four clerks
and we were not we were not all of the
same mind there was a mix
when you were there ever cases when you
went before justice scalia
and you you thought maybe he was leaning
one way where he actually listened to
the arguments from the clerk and
modified his position or was it like the
professor discussion
uh no i think he definitely listened i
mean we would go in before
an argument when he was preparing and he
would pepper us with questions and go
back and forth he wanted to hear it from
all sides
and so no he definitely it was part of
the give and take though to be clear
he was the one with the commission and
he was the one who made the decisions
thank you
the last thing i'm going to say because
i want to yield back more time than most
other members
as mr chairman you opened up this
morning talking about the affordable
care act i don't think there's anybody
in the u.s senate that doesn't want to
make sure that every single picture that
we've seen here
that those folks have affordable health
care and that they can be cared for
but what we have here in the affordable
care act is something
that is so flawed that the majority of
the democratic candidates for pro
for president all raised their hand and
said it needed to be replaced with
something they call medicare for all
which could be medicare for none
we know the broken promises of if you
like your doctor you could keep it if
you like your health care you could keep
it
what we're not talking about are the
thousands of people who were already
forced off of their job health care
because employers changed hours now
instead of working one full-time job
you've got to work two full-time jobs
because the businesses can't afford it
we've got a fundamental problem here we
need to protect every one of them but we
also need to make sure
that people who have a health plan under
the affordable care act can actually
afford to use it
in the catastrophic situations it's
life-changing and thank god that it's
there for them
but what about so many other people that
only have it and will only use it if
they
have a catastrophic situation because
they can't afford the co-pays they can't
afford the underlying costs
we need to fix that we shouldn't expect
the justice or the supreme court to fix
it
that is our job we should all show up
here for work and we should get
that done and we should also work on all
the other things that this country is
suffering from
as a result of cobit thank you judge
barrett i look forward to supporting
your nomination
thank you senator tillis thank you uh
senator hirano
thank you mr chairman mr chairman i want
to reiterate my
objections to holding this nomination
hearing instead of working
to provide relief for the millions of
americans who are suffering
during this pandemic three weeks ago our
country crossed
a tragic milestone we lost more than
200 000 americans to covet 19.
that is more than the entire population
of the big island in hawaii
more than the population of tempe
arizona cedar rapids
iowa wilmington north carolina
charleston south carolina waco texas
i could go on 200 000 american lives
less this is a photo of a memorial
outside the white house
where president trump held a reckless
super spreader event two weeks ago
to announce the supreme court nomination
the memorial shows 20 000
empty chairs one chair representing 10
american
lives lost to covet 19.
and one of those chairs represents
veronica
guevara's grandfather who is pictured
is pictured here with veronica veronica
who is from
iowa has experienced the painful impact
of the trump administration's failure
to address the pandemic her family is
composed of essential workers
who are working on the front lines of
this pandemic
her mother who worked at a fast
food processing facility caught covert
19 at work
and was eventually hospitalized for
seven
days thankfully her mother recovered
but then her grandparents got covet 19
and were admitted to the hospital and
although her grandmother recovered
sadly her grandfather didn't make it
after experiencing all of this tragedy
veronica shared quote it is even more
so insulting to see a senate that is
more concerned with rushing through
a supreme court nominee rather than
focusing on providing relief
to all the hard-working people that gave
them
their current leadership positions
end quote many americans agree
with veronica they are sitting at their
kitchen tables wondering
how they're going to buy food how
they're going to pay
rent millions of them are out of
they they don't have jobs they're going
to food banks
for the first time in their lives so
rather than coming up with a bill that
meets the needs
of the urgency of this moment
republicans are just come
coming up with peace mill bills
that's because we know that within your
own caucus
you can't agree on one bill that
fits the critical needs of this country
in fact there are at least 20
republicans
we heard who have said we're done
we're not doing any more to help the
americans who are suffering with covet
so here we are racing forward with this
nomination
while the rest of the country is
wondering what the heck
is the senate doing particularly the
senate republicans
so i agree with all the people in our
country who are asking what the heck
this is hypocritical this hearing shows
the american public
exactly what my republican colleagues
priorities are
ramming through another ideologically
driven justice to the supreme court
instead of helping the people in our
country suffering during this pandemic
mr chairman i have some letters of
opposition
to judge barrett's nomination to enter
into the record
these are letters from lambda legal
the japanese american citizens league in
the national
asian pacific american women's forum
which was joined by
55 reproductive justice groups
i ask unanimous consent to enter these
letters into the record
without objection judge barrett
chief justice john roberts has
recognized that and i quote him
the judicial branch is not immune and
quote from the widespread
problem of sexual harassment and assault
and has taken steps to address this
issue within the judiciary as part of my
responsibility as a member of this
committee and indeed all the committees
on which i sit
to ensure the fitness of nominees for a
lifetime appointment to the federal
bench or to any of the other
positions for any of the committees on
which they appear
i ask each nominee these two questions
and i will ask them of you
since you became a legal adult have you
ever made unwanted requests
for sexual favors or committed any
verbal or physical harassment or assault
of a sexual nature
no senator hirono have you ever faced
discipline or entered into a settlement
related to this kind of conduct no
senator
do you think it is appropriate for
justices to consider
real-world impacts in their
decision-making
as justice ginsburg noted in a number of
her descents
well senator the doctrine of star
decisis is a good example of that
because
the factor reliance interests takes into
account
um the real world impact the way that
people have ordered their affairs and
relied on decisions so there are
contexts yes
in which considering the impact is
expressly part of the doctrine
so you would say then you've been
listening to
all of us here yesterday as well as
today talk about the real world impact
of
the striking down of the affordable care
act
and would all of those impacts be
factors
that would be important for you to
consider should you be
a justice um senator to be clear
i have the utmost empathy the stories
you know that you have told including
the story of veronica's family are
very moving if i were a justice
the commitment that i would make to you
and all people affected by the laws
is that i would follow the law as you
enacted it and i have
no agenda i would not be coming in with
any agenda i would do
equal justice under the law for all and
not try to
thwart or or disrupt in any way the
policy choices
that you and your colleagues have
adopted so are you saying that
the impact of the affordable care act on
the millions of people who rely upon it
that those who
you would deem to be policy
considerations that
we should address senator
i think that you choose the law and
you've
structured the affordable care act it's
a complex long statute
i think you set the policy and then i
think when a court
has to interpret the statute or decide
how it applies in a certain circumstance
the court looks tradition traditional
legal materials looks to the briefs
it listens to the real world impact on
the litigants who are before the court
arguing the case
because every case affects real
litigants
every case affects real people i said in
my opening statement yesterday that
you know when you pass statutes they're
often named for the co-sponsors of the
bill
but cases decided by all courts are
typically named after the parties
they affect real people joshua so are
you saying that all of the stories that
we brought forth yesterday and the
millions of people
who are relying on the affordable care
act can
rely upon you that those impacts would
be considered
by you that you would consider those to
be
legal arguments that you would consider
because when you say that you're going
to make a decision
based on the law
the real life stories that we've been
talking about
you would consider those to be part of
the law
senator hirono every case that becomes
before a court
because as i was saying earlier no case
comes before a court unless it involves
real live people who've had a real live
dispute and it is the job of a judge
deciding
every case to take into account the real
world
real world consequences of the parties
before it
so does that mean that you would agree
with justice ginsburg that
the court should be taking into
consideration the real life effect of
the decisions that they make
because she wrote a number of these
dissents saying that the majority did
not consider
the real world impacts of their
decisions so are you
aligning yourself with justice ginsburg
in terms of
what you would consider real life
impacts and the
effect it would have on your decision
regarding the law
well senator i don't know what context
this the particular context in which
justice ginsburg
was describing that um i think what i'm
trying to align myself with
is the law and that i will take into
account all factors including real world
impacts when the law makes them relevant
as it clearly does for example in the
doctrine of starry decisis
i'll get to your views of president in a
moment
i'll give you a real life example of
justice ginsburg and libertar the
goodyear
tire and rubber company lilly ledbetter
worked at a goodyear plant for 19 years
as an area manager a position held
mostly by men
lily was paid less than all of her male
counterparts
when she eventually realized this stark
in
she sued for paid discrimination and the
jury agreed
but the supreme court kicked lily's
claim out of the court for being too
late
the conservative majority including your
mentor
justice scalia interpreted title 7's
180 day limit time limit to mean that
lily had to have father claim within 180
days
of when her salary was decided instead
of accepting the common sense approach
of viewing her paychecks as an ongoing
part
of pa discrimination justice ginsburg
strongly disagreed with her conservative
colleagues
approach to the case in her descent she
pointed out
the many challenges women face in
discovering pay disparities including
how many companies keep salaries
confidential
in a stinging rebuke she said quote the
court does not comprehend
or is indifferent to the insidious way
in which women can be victims of paid
discrimination end quote in another case
in 2018
in epic systems court v lewis employees
who have been illegally underpaid
joined together to see to seek back pay
in court
to block this effort their employers
forced them
to sign an arbitration agreement
prohibiting
collective actions they had to actually
have to sign these
arbitration agreements in order to even
have a job keep their job
so the supreme court's conservative
majority including justice scalia sided
with the company
they interpreted a general federal
arbitration law
to override two worker protections laws
instead of recognizing
that the worker protection laws fall
sensibly within the exceptions in the
arbitration law meaning that the worker
protection's laws
should prevail again justice ginsburg
strongly disagree with the majority's
approach to the case
in her dissent she pointed out that
blocking joint lawsuits would
deter most workers from seeking
individuals
unpaid individual unpaid wage claims
because
of the cost of lawsuits and fear of
retaliation
she warned the majority's decision would
result in hurting vulnerable
low-wage workers now those are the kinds
of real
life impacts the reality of women who
are
not paid the same as their male
counterparts because of
sex discrimination happening that she
has no way of finding out about
or of workers who are forced to sign an
arbitration clause
that overrides worker protection
other worker protection laws those are
the kind of real world impacts
so do you think justice ginsburg was
wrong to consider
real-world impacts in her
decision-making
well senator you know both the case you
know you're talking about
lilly ledbetter both that case and epic
systems are
precedents of the court and as i've said
a number of times during the hearing
i can't really comment or grade thumbs
up or thumbs down as justice kate will
put it
prior precedence or say how i would have
decided them
they are just barrett there are
presidents of the court
that do not take into consideration the
real world
factors at play here and in fact in the
case of epic systems the court
sided with the corporation as opposed to
the workers who are trying to remedy
iran and in lilly led better she was
totally out in the cold so again the
court did not so they established
precedent all right
but it was a president that was not
based on real life impacts so
much as you sit here telling me that you
would
follow the law after all the law
for example the affordable care act that
law
embodies a policy that says we want as
many people as possible to be covered
under insurance and if the affordable
care act is
struck down that policy that law would
be struck down so
i know that there was some discussion
about some distinction
that you make about policy
versus the law and i find that
distinction to be
a fiction because every law or most laws
we pass are supposed to have real world
impacts otherwise why should we pass the
law
so the fact that you're not able to
i think it's pretty clear let me
rephrase that you do
consider justice scalia to be your
mentor that your judicial philosophy
is in alignment with him and i think we
all acknowledge that justice scalia and
justice ginsburg were at pretty much
opposite ends of the spectrum
so since justice ginsburg made it a
policy
her approach was to look at the real
world impact
justice scalia's was not so
i'd say that when it comes to the
affordable care act
the real world policy considerations
that will not be taken into
consideration by the conservative
judges would mean that 23 million people
could lose their health care that 133
million americans with pre-existing
conditions
could lose critical protections for
their health care and more than
7 million americans who have tested
positive for covet 19
would probably be added to the group
of people with pre-existing conditions
and millions of americans would once
again
face lifetime limits on coverage for
essential
services that 8.7 million women would
lose coverage for critical maternity
care services
and we know that black and native women
are two to three times more likely to
die
than white women from pregnancy-related
cases that americans could lose coverage
for essential health benefits like
prescription drugs and mental health
care
that young adults will no longer be able
to stay on their parents health
insurance plan
until age 26 at a time when our country
is dealing with massive job losses
so in my view there
you have posed an artificial dis
distinction between policy
considerations that's left up to
us and following the law because
if your criticism of
justice roberts decision in upholding
the affordable care act
if if that was something that he
followed
he would have struck down the affordable
care act
that is that is your if he followed your
criticism of him in sustaining the
affordable care
act he would have struck it down
so i would conclude that your approach
is in fact
not like that of justice ginsburg who
did care
about what would happen let me just
tell you one story of a person who will
be
impacted in the real world if the
affordable care act is struck down
and i know that so many of my colleagues
have already established that the
president expects you to
strike down the affordable care act and
you've already established that you made
no such commitments
but clearly that is why this whole
process is occurring
occurring so that you can be sitting on
that court in time to hear the
affordable care act by the supreme court
on november
10. so one of the people who will be
impacted is elizabeth from texas she
moved to texas for a job
and thought that she would have a stable
income and health care coverage
and all that changed when her hours
decreased and she lost her health
insurance
because she couldn't afford health
insurance she couldn't get proper
treatment for her asthma
she had to resort to using friends
expired inhalers
and over-the-counter remedies the aca
allowed her to get health insurance
again the aca also protects people with
pre-existing conditions like jordan who
i talked about yesterday and she has a
very rare
illness that would require
500 000 per year just for her medication
and we're not for the affordable care
act she wouldn't to be able to afford it
i mean who can afford 500 000 a year to
keep her going and also people like
kimberly
i talked about her yesterday they say
enabled her to get a mammogram which she
wouldn't have been able to get and that
mammogram revealed that she
had breast cancer and
she got a mastectomy so you know this is
this the real life impacts on people
like
elizabeth jordan and kimberly where you
say you will follow the law
it really leaves me wondering whether
all of these real life impacts are
what you would call within the scope of
the law that you would
decide should you be confirmed november
10th you'll hear the case you will be
deciding
on the constitutionality of the
affordable care act and by the way you
noted that the
issue in the affordable care act was one
of
what was it that you said favorability
severability
but the other issue in the affordable
care act is the entire constitutionality
of the law
because the district court the issue is
whether the district court in texas was
correct
and deeming the entire law
unconstitutional so in fact we
are facing the entire law
falling by the wayside
let me move on so
you've been also asked a lot of
questions about whether or not you would
overturn roe v wade
i mean clearly president trump expects
that you would do so
because as he said if we put another two
or perhaps three justices
uh on the court that'll happen meaning
the
the reversal of robbie wade will happen
automatically in my opinion because i am
putting pro-life justices on the court
and the number of us have mentioned that
senator as far as senator
holly is concerned where he said i will
only vote for those supreme court
nominees
who have explicitly acknowledged that
roe v wade was wrongly decided
and there's a whole quote i have from
him but
after you were nominated senator holly
made clear that you passed his litmus
test and he said i think her record is
awfully clear
i think that's one where she meets my
standard of having evidence in the
record and by the way he had noted
that he expected this evidence in the
record not
from your post nomination assurances
to him so all your prior record he said
you met his standards so
we we usually expect justices to uphold
and apply
long-standing precedent so
uh was the president wrong in concluding
that you would
vote to overturn roe v wade
well senator again i can't make any
statements no hints forecasts or
previews as justice ginsburg put it
about any case or any precedent but i
will
repeat what i've said you know
throughout this hearing
that i made no promises to anyone i have
no agenda
there are 598 volumes of the united
states reports
that's something that judges build on
justices don't go to the court to start
having a book burning
i know that you have reiterated that
time and again but you know what we are
left with
are the positions that you have already
taken
so the 2006 newspaper ad you signed
that said you quote oppose arbitra
abortion on demand and defend the right
to life from fertilization to natural
death it's not just the fact that this
newspaper
ad you joined said what i just read but
it also said
quote it's time to put an end to the
barbaric legacy of roe v wade
in a 2013 speech you gave where you said
the road decision
quote permitted abortion on demand in
quote after you said you have
opposed abortion on demand in 2006.
so what underscores my concern about
your willingness to
overturn roe v wade which is really the
expectation that the president has and
which
senator holly fully expects you to do
because you have met his
litmus test but you know to start
decisis which is precedent
and you have argued that a justice's
duty to follow the constitution which
you explain means that she
should this is regarding your view on
precedent
that she should quote enforce her best
understanding of the constitution rather
than a precedent she thinks clearly in
conflict with it
end quote so in in fact you say
constitutional cases
are the easiest to overrule because you
bring your own
assessment of what the constitution
requires and as you said
if the president is clearly in conflict
with your view of
the constitution then the president
falls by the wayside so
you did indicate that there are a few
cases that are
immunized from overturning because
um they are they wouldn't be challenged
in the first place i.e
brown the bird of board of education but
roe
isn't one of those cases because we know
that
there are all kinds of challenges to
grow basically because the states are
very busy passing all these
these laws that limit a woman's right to
an abortion so you also said in that
speech
that even if roe is not overturned
you said without overturning roe
you explained quote the question is how
much freedom the court is willing to let
states have
in regulating abortion and so
there are 14 cases right now relating to
state abortion restrictions
making its way through the circuit court
and some of these are going to land
in the supreme court and these 14 cases
include the following restrictions
six cases involve bans on abortion
starting
at gestational ages ranging from six to
24 weeks
two cases involving bans on a particular
type of procedure dilation
and evacuation that accounts for nearly
all second trimester
abortions one case involving a
requirement that fetal remains be buried
or cremated
four cases involve laws imposing
unnecessary requirements
on abortion providers like transfer
agreements with local hospitals
four cases involve so-called reason bans
two cases related to parental
notification
and consent there are real reasons why
the american public is concerned
that you will overturn roe or basically
strip it of all meaning so that it
becomes a nullity because
you will have these cases that as you
say you know the
open question is how far the supreme
court will go
in letting states put limits on
abortion so
that is why a lot of people are very
concerned about your views
as articulated pre-nomination
which convinced senator holly you meant
his test this morning senator feinstein
asked you a question about the supreme
court's 2015 decision
in a bourgeois hodges a case in which
the court recognized
the constitutional right to same-sex
marriage and i was disappointed that you
wouldn't give a direct answer
whether you agreed with the majority in
that case or if you
instead agree with your mentor justice
scalia that no such right exists in the
constitution
so even though you didn't give a direct
answer i think your response did
speak volumes not once but twice
you use the term sexual preference
to describe those in the lgbtq community
and let me make clear sexual preference
is an offensive and outdated term
it is used by anti-lgbtq activists
to suggest that sexual orientation is a
choice
it is not sexual orientation is a key
part
of a person's identity that sexual
orientation
is both a normal expression of human
sexuality and
immutable was a key part
of the majority's opinion in a workflow
which by the way scalia did not agree
with
so if it is your view that sexual
orientation is merely a preference
as you noted then the lgbtq community
should be
rightly concerned whether you would
uphold their constitutional
right to marry i don't think that you
use the term sexual preference as just
i don't think it was an accident and one
of the legacies of justice scalia
and his particular brand of originalism
is a resistance
to recognizing those in the lgbtq
community
as having equal rights under our
constitution in 1996 justice scalia
wrote a dissenting opinion and
romer v evans defending a state's
ability to openly discriminate
against the lgbtq community in 2003
justice scalia
wrote a dissenting opinion in lawrence v
texas defending a state's right
to criminally prosecute someone for
same-sex sexual activity
ten years later in usv windsor justice
scalia wrote another
dissenting opinion this time defending
the federal government's right
to deny federal recognition of same-sex
marriages and of course two years after
that
in a booger fell justice scalia wrote
yet another dissent and this time he
argued that there was no constitutional
right
to same-sex marriage so under justice
scalia's judicial philosophy which you
have
told us is your own states could openly
discriminate against the lgbtq community
same-sex couples could be denied the
right to get married
and they could actually be thrown in
jail if they
engaged in sexual intercourse there are
an estimated 11 million adults who are
identified
as lgbtq living in this country
since obergefell was decided in 2013
2015 approximately 293 000 same-sex
couples
have gotten married and many of these
people
are rightly afraid that if you are
confirmed you will join with other
conservative members of the court to
roll back
everything the lgbtq community has
gained over the past two
decades and pushed them back into the
closet
now two sitting justices are already
calling for
a burgerfeld to be narrowed if not
outright overturned
just last week justices thomas and alito
issued a statement
concerning concurring with the court's
decision to deny cert in davis v
irmo a case involving a former kentucky
county court who refused
to issue marriage certificates to
same-sex couples
they accused the court of and this is
justices
alito and thomas they accused the court
of quote
reading a right to same-sex marriage
into the 14th amendment even though
that right is found nowhere in the text
and these two justices signal
that obergefell is a problem that only
the court
can fix so
coupled with your use of the term sexual
preference coupled with your view on
precedence and that a justice's view
or her own analysis of the
constitutionality
should overtake or overcome
precedence if it's in conflict
so this is why so many people in the
lgbtq community are
so concerned that you would in fact
join the signaling that these two
justices have already
put out there that a burger phil will
fall by the wayside
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
ernst
thank you mr chair and judge barrett
thank you so much
um for being here today with your
beautiful family yet
once again we appreciate the support
that you are showing
to judge barrett by being here today and
judge i just want to offer you the
opportunity at this point
is there anything from earlier today
that you feel you need more time to
respond to
um thank you senator ernst i would like
to just make a quick
follow-on to some of senator hirono's
comments
um one you know i've said a number of
times during the hearing
that i can't comment or grade existing
precedent and i want to be clear that
the point of doing that
is not to say whether i agree or
disagree with it it's not to implicitly
signal that i do disagree with it
it's designed to be neutral so in saying
that i couldn't opine on whether
obergefell was rightly decided or not
i would certainly not indicating
disagreement with it the point of not
answering is to simply say
it's inappropriate for me to say a
response and the second point was to say
that i certainly didn't mean
and you know would never mean to use a
term that would cause any offense in the
lgbtq community
so if i did i greatly apologize for that
i simply meant to be referring to
obergefell's holding
with respect to same-sex marriage thank
you for that i appreciate the
clarification
and it goes back to the discussion that
you had with senator sasse on the black
robes
um when you put that robe on you are
neutral
correct yes yes thank you so i did want
to go back because
clarify that the senate gop
did bring up a relief bill a number of
weeks ago
and in that bill there was a 300
boost in weekly unemployment insurance
benefits
there was a second pass at paycheck
protection program for our small
businesses
there was additional 105 billion for
k-12 schools and colleges
with new scholarship programs and 15
billion to help working parents
find accessible child care options there
were supports for farmers and ranchers
impacted by the pandemic there was
31 billion for development and
distribution of vaccines drugs and other
medical supplies
16 billion for testing and contract
contact tracing
there was loan forgiveness for the
postal service liability protections for
schools and health care providers and an
expanded charitable deduction
for contributions made during this
pandemic and many many other things
it was a very very good bill it was what
we could agree upon
but i would note that senate democrats
did block those provisions that would
have gone to help
families like veronica and others in
iowa that are suffering from the
pandemic and
are of course our greatest sympathies to
those that have been
impacted all across the united states
um so mr chairman i would like to enter
into the record there's three letters
here
uh for the committee committee and an
op-ed a letter of support from
48 christian women's scholars the second
is a letter from a group of governors
all across the country including
our own iowa's governor kim reynolds
strongly supporting the nomination of
judge barrett the third
is a record letter for
from tracy lovett uh who was with judge
barrett while they both served on the
scotus clerk class of 1998
and then there's also an editorial by
derek
muller a professor of law at the
university of iowa college of law
that appeared in the gazette of cedar
rapids iowa
and this professor had
judge barrett as his evidence professor
at notre dame law school and he does say
she treated all law students
from all backgrounds with dignity and
respect if i could have those entered
into the record without an objection
thank you and judge
i am pro-life i am pro-life and
i see that judged by your faith and as
has been
aptly pointed out many times over um by
our
colleagues across the aisle that that
you are
pro-life but once again can we reiterate
um your stance as a judge
um so as a judge my personal moral
beliefs
which i have not that i can think of i
i'm not expressing them publicly right
now because now that i am a judge
i can't sign statements like that one
that i did 15 years ago
um but my policy views my moral
convictions my religious beliefs do not
bear
on how i decide cases nor should they it
would be
you know and it would be in conflict
with my judicial oath
and i know that you consider yourself to
be an originalist
as you discussed earlier with senator
sasse and it seems that
adhering to the original originalist
view
would naturally lead a judge to carry
out her constitutional duty
of impartiality when applying the law
and adhering to this philosophy as a
judge takes
real courage and the courage you have
displayed thus far as a
federal judge prompted a coalition of
groups
to send me a letter supporting your
nomination
susan b anthony list led this coalition
letter that i would like to submit to
the committee for the record
and i know this is going to make a
number of
members on the committee just very
squeamish
because they are a pro-life organization
but with this in mind i want to take a
moment to read
part of this letter quote
judge barrett has proven herself to
handle disputes
impartially approaching cases as a
textualist
and originalist who loves the
constitution
she is a jurist who rightly leaves
politics
to politicians and legislating
to legislators and i'll quote further
quite apart from whatever policy views
she may have
on the matter judge barrett reasons to a
proper result
in each case before her as a federal
appellate judge appropriately following
controlling precedent
in february 2019 she joined a panel
decision
upholding a law creating a buffer zone
around abortion facilities
this buffer or bubble zone case being
referred to
as price versus city of chicago
judge barrett could you please give us
an overview
of the city ordinance that was
challenged here and explain how
precedent
established by the supreme court's hill
decision
influenced your reasoning of the case
yes i was on a panel there was a
challenge to a bubble zone ordinance
which
essentially means um it was
how to describe it it limited where
abortion protesters could go to do
sidewalk counseling or leafleting with
the things that they
identified as the activities they
desired to undertake
in the expression of speech outside of
the abortion clinic
the supreme court has a case called hill
versus colorado
and that case said that such bubble
zones especially because this one in
chicago
was nearly identical as i recall with
the one that was at stake in hill
said that they did not violate the first
amendment and so
our panel you know we're bound by that
precedent our panel
applied that precedent and so as you say
that was a case involving abortion but
my duty
as a judge was to follow the governing
law and that governing law and that case
was hill
absolutely and thank you for that
clarification and i think it was
important to point
that out because in that case
using precedent it did favor
that abortion clinic is that correct
that is correct thank you very much um
so i would like to
submit this for the record thank you
now turning to a topic of agency
rule-making really sexy topic not
something that we have
not something that we have talked about
um as of yet
but as i mentioned yesterday when
congress makes laws that overstep the
constitution
it can be felt all across the state of
iowa
whether it's in the streets of council
bluffs iowa
or in the farm fields over in clinton
county
but congress isn't the only body capable
of
overstepped executive agencies can be
just as guilty as the of this as we've
seen
in iowa in 2018
as a judge on the seventh circuit you
helped decide a clean water act
case specifically orchard hill building
company versus
army corps of engineers the decision
found that the federal government did
not provide enough evidence to justify
its decision to deem
13 acres of illinois wetlands
as a water of the u.s i'm very
supportive of a
less expansive definition of wotus and
am encouraged by how you approach this
decision
farmers in iowa are also encouraged by
this development
i believe then as i do now that the
obama administration's clean water rule
or the wotus rule was unconstitutional
but i also want to talk to you about
agency rule-making
that i believe was constitutional
which is illustrated in a a case that
the 10th circuit court has recently
ruled on specifically
renewable fuels association versus epa
at issue in this case were three
exemptions the epa granted to oil
companies
allowing them to avoid their obligations
to blend renewable fuel under the clean
air act's renewable fuel
standard these oil refinery exemptions
which were not disclosed to the public
were challenged by renewable fuel
producers
who said that they only found out about
the waivers
because of investigative news reports
the 10th circuit concluded in this case
that the renewable fuels producers were
injured
by the epa's exemptions and thus had
standing to sue
the court also found that the epa
exceeded
its statutory authority in granting
those petitions
because the agency may only extend
previously existing waivers in the case
of these three refiners
there was nothing to extend because they
had let their exemptions
lapse in other words the three
refineries had not received continuously
extended
extended exemptions in the years
preceding their petitions as required
by the statute however in the wake of
this 10th circuit decision small
refineries flooded the epa with 67
petitions
for retroactive waivers some dating back
as far as
2011 in an attempt to go back in time
and establish a chain of continuously
extended exemption these oil companies
have also appealed to the 10th circuit
decision
to or the 10th circuit decision to the
supreme court
so while i'm not going to ask you to
speak on all of this
and what is going on um the problem here
bottom line is that the epa wasn't
following the law
they took the law that congress passed
they twisted it
and interpreted it for the benefit of
oil producers
and that hold our iowa farmers
i know again you can't speak on how you
would rule
rule on these cases especially those
that could be pending before the supreme
court
but tell me how do agencies how should
they interpret the laws that are passed
by congress
well i think that the court's role in
reviewing the lawfulness
of agency action it's largely governed
by the administrative procedure act
which governs the way that agencies can
do their business
and and outlines what their authority
can be there's also a doctrine called
chevron which is named after a case and
many times if we're talking about a
chevron issue we're talking about an
issue of statutory interpretation
it sounds like that's mostly what you're
thinking of and
an agency you know when a court reviews
whether an agency has exceeded its
lawful authority
it goes to the statute that you and
congress
and interprets that statute looks at the
text
and tries to tell whether you've given
given the agency given the epa in your
example
leeway to adopt policies and that leeway
would be present if you
had ambiguity in the statute that left
the decision to the agency
but if the agency goes farther than the
text of the statute permits
then it is the role of a court to say
that that action
you know was in conflict with the
statute and therefore
illegal and what happens then if there
is an
actual question on the intent of the law
um well a statute in this context
in a context of a chevron type challenge
to
agencies an agency's interpretation of
it you would interpret the statute in
the same way that you would interpret
any other statutes so as i was talking
with senator sas about earlier
my own approach to it would be
textualism
and so in my approach to language the
intent of the statute is best expressed
through the words
so looking at what the words would
communicate to a skilled user of the
language
very good well i appreciate it we do
have a little bit of time remaining so
again i just want to thank you i want to
thank your family very much for lending
their support to you through this
process it can be a bit grueling um but
i do have to say though your
temperament throughout the entire
hearing has been truly commendable
so thank you so much i look forward to
working with you further
and with that mr chair i will
uh reserve my time thank you senator uh
judge are you okay to do two more
sure so senator booker senator crypo
then we'll take a
20 minutes so break grab by date and
finish up senator booker
thank you uh mr chairman your honor hi
senator
uh so i spoke yesterday and i appreciate
the
attention which you gave me talking
about how this is not a normal time
and i want to reiterate that uh one more
time as cogently as i
can because this is um something like
we've just never seen before in the
history of the united states
we're not just days away from election
day but people are
actually voting right now close to a
million people in my state
have already voted and about 10 million
people
voted nationally the only other time a
supreme court nomination hearing
happened this close to an election was
as you probably know was under president
lincoln
who declined to offer a nomination
before the election but we are in the
midst of an ongoing election right now
at a very contentious time in our
democracy it's probably not normal also
because
uh people are already speaking in this
election and
it seems like we are rushing through
this process
when many of my colleagues on this
committee said just four years ago
uh that we should not proceed to fill a
vacancy that opened
269 days before an election and the
words of some of my colleagues including
the chairman was to use our words
against us we would not do
exactly what we're doing right now
it's also not normal clearly uh because
we're in the middle of a pandemic
and we have tens of thousands of new
coveted infections
every single day widespread food
insecurity like we haven't seen
these kind of food lines in my lifetime
i don't think
people across our country are struggling
and unfortunately we see
that we are right now not dealing with
this crisis
we are instead uh literally having
closed the senate virtually
and the only proceedings are being
allowed to go forward are not the issues
of helping people who are struggling
but dealing with this and it's not
normal that we have a president
who has repeatedly attacked the
legitimacy of our institutions
so much so and i've never seen something
like this in my lifetime that his former
cabinet members
his former chief of staff all talk about
the danger he represents to
uh the country we all love in fact
probably one of the most respected
person on both sides of the aisle
general mattis who served as our
secretary of defense went as far as to
say a man
who has been very reserved in his
comments that donald trump is a danger
to our democracy we are at a time
that the legitimacy of our institutions
are at stake
and it's not normal that the president
would further cast a shadow over your
nomination as well as
the independence of the court by saying
he would only
nominate justices who would tear down
roe v wade who would overturn
aca and it's not normal
amidst this all and again something that
i find hard to believe that we're
talking about is that we have a
president who cannot commit himself
to the peaceful transfer of power